it is almost time for the vegas strong
5k the annual event raises money for
those impacted by the deadly 1 october
mass shooting here to talk about the
race is cynthia gainey with jess run
the organizer of this race
that made it all possible
all the way back five years ago cynthia
thanks for being here this morning you
have stuck with this event year after
year and
tell me about it let's go back five
years because after one october within
just one month you put on this amazing
event and what was the response like
well it was more than we had anticipated
and uh we initially were just going to
put on this one race to raise as much
money as we could for the victim funds
and then after the race
people just inundated us with messages
and
phone calls saying please continue it
it's it's uh it really helped them
you know support wise coming together
that sort of thing so it was more it was
more than just the money it was just
giving a space for people to come
together
survivors uh families of victims first
responders and people in the community
that weren't even at the concert they
just wanted to come together and support
each other right it started the healing
process
which had not even barely begun a month
later but through the years tell me
about the healing because you survived
the pandemic with this event you did
virtual registrations you still had
hundreds even thousands of people that
still want to participate in this event
because of what happened five years ago
on one october
yeah i mean it's it's incredible that um
everybody is coming together still
and i've talked to several people
people
families of victims and people that had
were at the concert and they're still
going through a healing process it's in
them it's nowhere near but this is a a
this foot race you know it's you know
you're putting one foot in front of the
other to get to the finish line and it's
kind of
what they like about it is that it keeps
them moving forward
um to continue healing
and coming together and so um
even though we covet
hit us it didn't stop people from coming
together but we're so happy to be back
at downtown again this year because now
we can have as many people that want to
come out no limits no limits that's good
tell us how tell everybody how they can
sign up you're back in person downtown
people can gather together you've got
people coming again from out of state uh
what what is registration and what are
the deadlines people need to know well
we're over 1200 uh participants right
now uh we today or tomorrow regis the
price increases so register today
how much is that it's uh it's 45 today
and it'll be 50 tomorrow for the 5k
and um i mean we have
uh
a large group from canada coming back
into town because they haven't been able
to come because of coat over the last
couple years we have over 100 people
coming from california
we have
several over 85 teams we have teams of
police officers and firefighters that
are going to be participating we have
the women's marines group that are going
to be out there so and you've got
co-workers and families and everybody
coming together it's a great event and
i'm happy to be able to emcee again this
year it is going to be downtown you can
find out more about the vegas strong 5k
you can scan this qr code that's on your
screen right now the event is sunday
october 2nd it's the day after there are
so many events going on on the 1st of
october right and this will be 8 a.m on
sunday morning october 2nd so
cynthia gainey again thank you so much
look forward to it and thank you for
continuing this tradition year after
year you i know people are looking
forward to coming back thank you for
your support as well absolutely happy
too